if you follow me on instagram welcome to
the party and thank you
you know that i love to share tips and
tricks to all things from design
to beauty and i actually posted a video
using crest
which i just posted because i love it
and i've been using it my whole life
and it whitens my teeth and i'm a die
hard so crest saw the video
and reached out to see if we could team
up and i thought
uh yes please count me in
so we're gonna celebrate what they say
is their strongest whitening toothpaste
yet
oh crest 3d white brilliance
i'm so excited well they're making
people smile
so let me introduce you to someone who's
really going to put a smile
on your face like she did to mine she's
a brilliant young woman doing brilliant
things
at just 17 years old she's the innovator
behind talking masks
which are specifically designed for
those who need to read lips
please welcome seventeen-year-old
isabella appella
hi bethella hello
i'm so excited to be here today i am so
glad that we've been brought together
i love your story so much
and i'm going to start by saying
obviously masks are a reality
of the world right now and you wanted to
take a different approach
will you please tell me about what you
did
yeah so i created talking mass at the
beginning of quarantine
which my goal with that was to raise
awareness for the deaf and hard of
hearing community
during this time and with
this talking mass as you can see it has
a clear window on it which allows for
those who rely
on lip reading to communicate do so and
you don't profit off of this do you
no i make no profit at all every
donation goes directly to the hearing
aid project
which provides hearing aids those who
cannot afford them themselves
well i know we all love you here so much
i also heard on top of being a pioneer
and a businesswoman
and an all-around do-gooder you just
became
president of your school yes
i did last week okay what's your first
order of business
um okay well obviously during this time
bringing together my school as a
community is so important to me
so my goal with that is to invite
one board representative from every club
on campus
to student council and that way we can
help them with events
maybe hang posters for them or just get
more people involved in their club in
general
do you like to have a nice like
well-rounded out group that represents
different
needs viewpoints interests so that you
can really diversify for your school
yeah that's one of the main goals of my
um of me being in student council this
year actually
that's what i was getting the sense of
um i just i admire that so much
i just think when we can come together
um
i i'm so in favor of that and
we're so impressed with you here we're
in awe of
all the things you're accomplishing and
we're going to be donating
5 000 to the hearing aid project of
yours and
target is going to give you a thousand
dollar gift card for
supplies thank you so much
actually thank you isabella and we can't
wait to watch you take over the world
one bright smile at a time thank you
thank you isabella and when chris teamed
up with us they actually told
our whole team that they truly believe
in their product because they want
people to have confidence
to unleash their own smile that's
actually seriously a term that they
and their team uses ready unleash your
smile
and if crest 3d white brilliance can
encourage you to have a little more
confidence on your next zoom
well that's what they did for me so i
think we can all
smile together now thanks to crest